Donald Trump vuelve a la gran manzana
por segunda vez en menos de 10 días pero
esta vez lo hace para presentarse en la
oficina de la fiscal general del estado
de Nueva York Leticia James por una
demanda civil que ha presentado esta
fiscal contra Donald Trump contra la
organización Trump y contra tres de sus
hijos asegura la demanda de unas 200
páginas que la familia Trump falsificó
documentos para inflar el valor de sus
bienes y así obtener mayores beneficios
da algunos ejemplos en esa extensa
demanda Como por ejemplo el de un
edificio que se encuentra muy cerquita
de aquí en la 40 de Wall Street tiene
varias oficinas y un gran supermercado
Pues bien la familia Trump dijo que el
valor de este edificio era el doble de
lo que en realidad vale hizo lo mismo
con el apartamento que tiene la Quinta
avenida en la torre Trump donde
precisamente durmió ayer por la noche el
expresidente asegurando que el tamaño de
ese apartamento era mucho mayor del que
en realidad era la investigación detrás
de la demanda duró cerca de tres años
eso es lo que ha dicho la fiscal James y
arrancó Precisamente en el 2019 después
de que él es abogado de Donald Trump
Michael cohen dijera ante el congreso
algunas confesiones respecto a las
empresas de Donald Trump entre ellas la
que derivó en la trama de stormi Daniels
y también confesó que la organización
trama habría inflado el precio de
algunas propiedades para obtener mayores
beneficios y había infravalorado el
precio de otras para obtener también
beneficios Fiscales Pues bien a raíz de
estas declaraciones la fiscal general
del estado de Nueva York comenzó la
investigación Y hoy ha citado aquí a
Donald Trump para declarar por este por
esta demanda civil